so we all know some of the big names in
Techo history xan Moore alien John
Charlie Cushing but what about Leonardo
aaza does the name not ring a bell what
about if I asked if you're familiar with
body tracers or what about horizontal
stacking what if I told you that Leo
iaza had an enormous hand in either
defining or outright creating these
categories of petrix And yet when we
talk about the big names that Define the
genre I almost never hear his name come
up so how about we fix
[Music]
that Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today
I'm doing a deep dive into the most
influential po spinner you've never
heard of but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrro teror light
toys spinballs and Ultra for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca Becken thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission so first to answer the
obvious question who exactly is Leonardo
aaza Leo iaza is a Mexican poy spinner
who has been spinning and posting
content for almost as long as I have I
first became aware of Leo when he began
posting to the Facebook Tech poy group
back when it was essentially the only po
group on the platform I started crossing
paths with him on the fire Festival
circuit and while I enjoyed his presence
he didn't really stand out to me all
that much as a pois spinner but that
changed radically in 2010 Leo W on a hot
streak of placing himself in the right
place at the right time to have an
enormous influence over emerging
categories of poy tricks defining
Frameworks that are still commonly in
use today and like I've talked a lot
about many of his contemporaries names
like alien John and Rona McLaughlin are
certainly already enshrined in the
animals of Techo history but how many of
us actually spend like either of them
when was the last time you performed a
unit circle hybrid what's your favorite
vertical stack but if I asked you about
horizontal stacking or even body tracing
I'm willing to bet you could conjure up
several favorites quite easily and you
know what you pretty much have Leo to
thank for that so how did Leo wind up
having such a huge impact and more
importantly how did he wind up a
footnote in Techo history instead of one
of our most celebrated thinkers to
understand that I want to explore
exactly why I think he's so
influential part one tracing
history here's a fun secret several
years ago I discovered there was a
magical poy term that was solid gold for
search results on YouTube if the title
of your video included the words body
Tracer the video was guaranteed to break
a thousand views in the first 24 hours
nowadays body tracers are such a
Cornerstone of Po spinning that it's
difficult to remember there was a time
in the POI world before they were
recognized as discret po moves let alone
even existed here's a PO history trivia
question for you do you know who first
invented body tracers well in all
honesty I don't either but I'm pretty
sure I can tell you who invented the
idea poy tricks that involved moving the
hands along different lines of the body
have been around for quite a while in
fact I've long argued that tuck turns
could be considered a form of body
tracing and those go back decades and
even if you were to find the first body
Tracer in po history I very much doubt
the person performing it would have
thought of it as such
there were countless po moves that had
body tracing characteristics that were
floating around for years before they
were ever considered part of the same
framework much of the work of UDA
imamura and Thomas Johansson would
certainly be considered body tracers now
and had been around for quite some time
but it was Leo that identified that
something unique and special was going
on in these tricks see nobody had
thought to put all these tricks together
and apply a label to them because in
many cases they didn't seem as though
they were related petrix at all but Leo
saw something different and he exploded
onto the scene with a video entitled
body tracing on December 2nd 2010 and
the POI world would never be the same he
saw these tricks not in terms of the
patterns the POI were creating but in
terms of the relationship the performers
hands had with their body he likened
this technique to the one from liquid
dancing called tracing and had a Eureka
moment hence body tracing to the best of
my knowledge nobody before Leo had
applied this label to this type of pyra
independently it became a huge fixture
of the Russian pois spinning style and I
can remember back in 2011 Israeli pois
spinner aoft more referring to it
pejoratively as Tech given the
degree of contact the performer had with
their body seemed to indicate throws of
Ecstasy but thus far I've yet to
encounter this specific label being used
before Leo coined it but he didn't just
name this type of poy trick Leo's
contributions to this field go a lot
deeper Leo dissected what made body
tracers tick and came came up with the
idea of thinking of them as being made
up of reels located in various points
around the body this gives us not just a
series of exercises to drill but also a
recipe for creating brand new body
tracers in the process again it wasn't
unusual for people to practice reels
around their shoulders or waist before
and drilling reels with your hand behind
your back was not infrequently seen as a
stepping stone to getting down behind
the back weaves but taking that same
technique and applying it to every major
point of interest on the body that was
definitely something new in fact to this
day I still teach this as a tool for
getting down and creating new body
tracers plus which the ability to hold
down reels in each spot around the body
is just a helpful skill to have and it
was something we didn't really do to
this extent before Leo came onto the
scene even if he just named the field of
body tracing that honestly would be
enough to guarantee Leo a spot in the
annal of poi history but he wasn't
finished with his hot streak just yet
and on February 9th 2011 he opened up a
second framework of Po moves that
radically changed the way that we
thought about and looked at
POI part two stacking
history so if I was to ask most of you
about horizontal stacking I'm willing to
bet there is one name that would come to
mind Ivan Mel gorinov Mel introduced the
tech poy world to horizontal stacking
with a short and innocuous POI pattern
tucked several minutes into his seminal
work red pants from July 2010 it fit in
among several other patterns for being
made up of a combination of stalls and
pendulums and making use of a staggered
stall pattern that defied common
understandings of timing and Direction
but the thing is that's the one and only
stacking pattern that Mel is showing off
in that video this is an entire genre of
petrix now so if Mel was only showing
off one where did the others come from
I'll confess that I more or less ignored
that pattern when the video first came
out but a rising CH of close friends
singled it out as an object of
Fascination and so I joined several
online discussions centering around it
it was in one of those discussions that
Leo pointed out an observation that
rocked the tech poy world see Mel's
pattern fit in among a host of his other
stall and pendulum based patterns but
Leo saw something very different in it
he saw a microcosm of Po flowers and
hybrids see one way to look at Mel's
pattern is to think of it as a pair of
top stalls with one book ended by
Pendulum but Leo saw something a little
more complex here he saw a two- petal
inpin flower that had been cut in half
and that meant that conceivably you
could come up with similar patterns for
any other type of Po flower
wait what suddenly we were all Off to
the Races Leo's framework gave us all a
new way to understand not just Mel's
original stacking pattern but a means of
creating new ones using the same
approach I was one of many people that
uploaded a video outlining a host of
ideas based around Leo framework before
long we were creating not just
flower-based horizontal stacking
patterns but also hybrids linear
isolations and many more Leo's Insight
drove the development of an entire
category of Po moves that remain alive
and vital to this very day there's some
irony in the fact that Mel gets sole
credit for horizontal Stacks given that
it was really Leo's Insight that turned
it into such an active pocket of the PO
world but it's also hardly the first or
even last time that a particular po move
gets attached to a specific spinner for
dubious reasons and yes I'm looking at
you xan's Diamond Leo himself uploaded a
video of his own exploring the many
directions his own insights had led him
to Leo wasn't afraid to contort his body
in a variety of ways to achieve a
specific pattern and the results could
vary from looking intriguing to
downright painful while we still didn't
have the phrase horizontal stacking to
describe this phenomenon the framework
was most definitely in place and hosts
of people free years to come including
myself Teddy Petroski Charlie Cushing
Liz Knights and countless more were all
cribbing from Leo's notebooks as we
explored these patterns for
ourselves part three a critical
reappraisal it's been really interesting
going back through a lot of Leo's old
work as I was working on this video and
realizing just how much crazy stuff he
had his hands in his most popular video
Uncharted POI includes an entire section
of intricate horizontal plane po tricks
that frankly would be considered Cutting
Edge even if you dropped them in a video
today to say nothing of the incredible
assortment of stall and pendulum based
patterns that were embellishing on his
horizontal stacking framework to create
even Wilder patterns to me it seems like
there's some irony in the fact that we
ascribe an enormous level of importance
and influence to people who are big
names but whose techniques rarely find
use in the modern poy World alien John
Rose to prominence with his unit circle
Theory a method of categorizing a
specific set of hybrids that was wildly
influential on how future Tech poy
theorists would create families of
movement but I rarely see it in use
among modern poy Spinners like do you
even cat eybrow Charlie kushen likewise
became a celebrity in the tech po scene
for developing nine square Theory and
its successor qft but how many of us
have used a translation recently or know
our way around a Nate step cap but body
tracers and horizontal stacking those
are Staples of the modern pois scene
those are things that damn near
everybody uses in a way I kind of
suspect that the difficulty and opak
andess of many of the tech po Giants
techniques is part of what adds to their
mystique and reputation whereas when we
talk about moves that have become
commonplace it gets a lot easier to take
them for granted and to be clear this is
not me throwing shade at alien John
Charlie or any of the other Techo
artists that I've mentioned in this
video it's merely to point out that as
we construct our Pantheon of Po names
there are absolutely a few notable
emissions and we ought to work to fix
that I'll also admit that in appraising
Leo's style nearly a decade and a half
ago I had a difficult time getting past
his odd contortions and the awkward
positions he would squeeze himself into
to achieve certain Poise shapes that
wasn't really what I wanted to look like
as a PO spinner so I didn't pay all that
much attention but with the benefit of
hindsight I have to say that I think Leo
might just be one of the most
influential po Spinners of that
generation not just because he created
ideas that were hugely influential but
because you can still see his impact
absolutely everywhere in the poy world
to this day aside from Nick woy I
honestly have a hard time coming up with
another po spinner whose work has so
deeply saturated the poy world as to
simply just be what we think of as poy
in a modern context that kind of
ubiquity is really rare and pretty
special so I personally would like to
thank Leo for all of his contributions
and apologize for how long it took me as
well as others to recognize them Leo you
are truly a Pioneer and we are all lucky
to have had your contributions in this
community part four wrapping
up if you haven't already I really
recommend going through Leo's back
catalog to see some of the stuff he was
working on at the height of the tech poy
boom I'll include a link down in the
description not only is it a really
eye-opening glimpse into some of the
cool stuff that was being developed at
the time but also a really fascinating
Time Capsule of an exciting moment in po
history Leo himself continues to upload
every so often and perhaps there's
something in his recent portfolio that
will likewise look back on in a decade
or so and realize that he seed the seeds
of something we all take for granted
then but I also imagine that Leo might
not be the only underappreciated POI
Pioneer out there so if you all have
people you'd like to see me cover in
future video essays like this one leave
me a comment with their name and why you
think they deserve a reappraisal in the
meantime please make sure to like like
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video and of course to help my
channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without the wonderful support of my
backers on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
here thank you so much for supporting my
channnel my work and my mission and if
you out there watching enjoy watching
video essays diving into lost corners of
the PO world like this one you can make
sure to help me make more of them by
signing up to support my work on patreon
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor poo there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that
support my mission to bring po spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world do
check that out please and thank you and
if you'd like to see me do another deep
dive into the career of another po
luminary you might enjoy this video I
did on why Nick Wy was way more
revolutionary and influential than we
give him credit for I'll link to that
down in the description as well as up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace